[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien schön dass Sie dabei sind
guten Abend Katja später mit allem was
im Sport ansteht und Anstand genau
schwere Krawalle in Frankreich nach dem
Tod eines Jugendlichen bei einer
Polizeikontrolle ist das Land in Aufruhr
in mehreren Städten gibt es
Gewaltausbrüche
diskriminiert und ausgegrenzt
muslimfeindlichkeit ist nach einem
Bericht in Deutschland weit verbreitet
auf in die Zukunft in Brandenburg ist
eine Fabrik zur Herstellung von Batterie
Rohstoffen eröffnet worden
[Musik]
Trauer Entsetzen und Wut in Frankreich
brodelt ist nach dem Tod eines
17-jährigen bei einer Polizeikontrolle
ist es in Paris und anderen Städten zu
teils schweren Krawallen gekommen gegen
den Verdächtigen Beamten wird jetzt
ermittelt und im Pariser Vorordnung
Terre kam es vor wenigen Stunden bei
einem Trauer und Protestmarsch wieder
zur Ausschreitung Thomas Walde berichtet
Nachmittag geht ein Trauerzug durch non
Terre der auch eine Demonstration ist
die Teilnehmer fordernd Gerechtigkeit
für nael sie rufen Gerechtigkeit gibt es
nirgends Polizei überall
wir sind heute hier weil ein
menschliches Leben ein Kind umgebracht
wurde ohne Rechtfertigung von den
Ordnungskräften
die Teilnehmer folgen in einem Aufruf
der Mutter des 17-Jährigen
Trauermarsch an der Präfektur am 14 Uhr
macht eine Revolte bitte für meinen Sohn
die gab es schon in der Nacht in
zahlreichen Städten Frankreichs
Polizisten und Rathäuser wurden
angegriffen es gab 150 Festnahmen
Präsident macron verurteilte heute die
Krawalle
die vergangenen Stunden waren geprägt
durch Gewaltakte gegen eine Polizeiwache
Schulen Rathäuser also gegen die
Institutionen und die Republik diese
Handlungen sind durch nichts
zurechtfertigen
ausgelöst wurden die Krawalle nachdem
ein Polizist bei einer Verkehrskontrolle
nahe im erschoss der junge Mann war der
Polizei wegen mehrere Delikte bekannt
der Staatsanwalt ermittelt gegen den
Beamten wegen Totschlags die
Staatsanwaltschaft ist der Auffassung
dass die Waffe nicht rechtmäßig
eingesetzt wurde die Empörung ist groß
nachdem im vergangenen Jahr 13 Menschen
bei Verkehrskontrollen getötet wurden im
Anschluss an den Trauermarsch gab es
enorm neue Krawalle und konfr ontationen
mit der Polizei 40.000 Beamte sollen am
Abend landesweit eingesetzt werden
sehr aufgeheizte Stimmung Thomas Walter
in Paris welche Bedeutung hat dieser
Fall für Politik und Gesellschaft
er hat zu viel Sprengkraft weil etwas
ganz grundsätzliches berührt viele
Jugendliche in der bornhöhe den
Brennpunkten werfen der Polizei
strukturelle Gewalt vor Rassismus und
Diskriminierung die Beamten entgegnen
gerade dort in diesen Gegenden sehen sie
sich besonders viel Kriminalität
gegenüber und sie sein es die
angegriffen werden es gibt zahlreiche
Spannungen in der französischen
Gesellschaft die sich bei verschiedenen
Gelegenheiten entladen das haben wir
gesehen bei den geldwesten Protesten den
Protesten gegen die Rentenreform und
jetzt eben auch wieder die politischen
extreme von links und rechts die heizen
das ganze bei jeder Gelegenheit eher an
darum verhallen die Appelle der
Regierung auch jetzt wieder doch bitte
Ruhe zu bewahren das Ganze kann also
noch ein bisschen weitergehen oder sich
bei der nächsten Gelegenheit wieder
entzünden vielen Dank nach Paris Thomas
Walde
bevor sich die eu-staats- und
Regierungschefs in die Sommerpause
verabschieden trafen sie sich noch mal
zum Gipfel in Brüssel das Thema
gemeinsame Flüchtlingspolitik bleibt
eine ziemlich harte Nuss und das liegt
an Ländern wie Polen und Ungarn
einfacher ist es da ein Bekenntnis zu
erneuern das Bekenntnis die Ukraine
weiterhin umfangreich zu unterstützen
Florian
die Frage an die Menschen vor den
Mikrofonen ist seit dem Wochenende
dieselbe was ist in Russland wirklich
los in Brüssel beim EU-Gipfel gibt es
heute viele Theorien und eine offene
Antwort ich bin lieber ehrlich ich weiß
das Politiker immer sagen ja ja
kompliziert mal nein keine Ahnung oder
droht eine neue Front in Belarus
südöstlich der Hauptstadt Minsk ein
bisher verlassener Militärstützpunkt
Satellitenaufnahmen von Samstag zeigen
dass die Gebäude noch leer standen auf
Aufnahmen von Dienstag sind neue
Strukturen zu erkennen womöglich für
Söldner der Wagner Truppe das nährt
sorgen in angrenzenden EU-Staaten sorgen
die der Bundeskanzler zu zerstreuen
versucht wir müssen genau beobachten was
da geschieht und in welcher Dimension
das der Fall ist in der NATO haben wir
uns Beistand versprochen jeder Angriff
auf NATO territoris eine Sache die wir
gemeinsam beantworten werden passend
dazu Besuch von Nato-Generalsekretär
Jens S ist Stoltenberg beim EU-Gipfel
später versichert man dem zugeschalteten
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski der
Ukraine so lange beizustehen wie nötig
kein EU-Gipfel aber auch ohne Streit die
härteste Kampfansage wird diesmal auf
polnisch formuliert mir nein zum gerade
geschlossenen Asylkompromiss der
EU-Staaten der Zahlungen vorsieht von
Ländern die keine geflüchteten aufnehmen
wollen
Migration
Nein zu finanzstrafen und Sanktionen und
ein Nein zu einer Entscheidung ohne
Einstimmigkeit
noch ist unklar ob Polen und Ungarn dass
ich ebenfalls wird mit ihrem Widerstand
etwas erreichen der Gipfel ist angesetzt
bis morgen Nachmittag
gehen wir nach Brüssel zu ultra Ulf die
EU schafft es nicht das Thema gemeinsame
Flüchtlingspolitik abzuräumen ist der
Asylkompromiss der EU Innenminister
jetzt wieder vom Tisch
nein er ist nicht vom Tisch sondern um
im Bild zu bleiben er liegt eben jetzt
wieder auf dem Verhandlungstisch im
Moment wird darüber gesprochen und
dieser historisch Moment von dem wir vor
wenigen Wochen gesprochen haben dass es
eine Einigung gibt danach sieht es eben
nicht mehr so aus vor allem zwei Länder
stellen diese gemeinsame
Flüchtlingspolitik in Frage wollen
Verschärfung und das sind Ungarn und
Polen sie sagen sie wollen keine
Flüchtlinge aufnehmen und sie sagen sie
wollen auch keine Strafzahlung an die EU
machen wenn sie eben keine Flüchtlinge
aufnehmen das sind zwei Kernelemente
dieses Kompromisses und wenn jetzt Polen
und Ungarn aus der europäischen
Solidarität rausgeht dann stellt man
eigentlich diesen Kompromiss in Frage
und das alles findet statt vor einer
noch anderen Sache das nämlich auch das
Europäische Parlament noch diesem
Kompromiss zustimmen muss und die wollen
auch noch nach verhandeln also Fazit
diese gemeinsame Flüchtlingspolitik die
man vor wenigen Wochen gefeiert hat ist
eben noch nicht historisch sondern es
sind noch viele Fragezeichen danke und
Grüße nach Brüssel
jetzt zu einem Urteil des Obersten
Gerichtshofs der USA das heftige
Reaktionen auslöst die konservative
Mehrheit der Richter hat die Bevorzugung
vor allem afroamerikanischer
Studienplatz Bewerber für illegal
erklärt die Hautfarbe dürfe bei der
Auswahl keine Rolle spielen heißt es in
dem Urteil ziel der Regelung war es
Afroamerikanern einen besseren Zugang zu
Bildungseinrichtungen zu ermöglichen und
so jahrzehntelange Benachteiligung von
Minderheiten auszugleichen
ja das ist gerade noch mal abgewendet
worden die Bahngewerkschaft EVG hat
einer Schlichtung im Tarifkonflikt
zugestimmt womit Warnstreiks vorerst vom
Tisch sind Bahn und Gewerkschaft wollen
jetzt so schnell wie möglich unter
externer Vermittlung eine Lösung finden
sollte das Ergebnis nicht überzeugen
drohe ein heißer Herbst so der EVG
Verhandlungsführer
die Inflationsrate ist im Juni nach
vorläufigen Zahlen wieder gestiegen auf
6,4% im Vergleich zum Vorjahresmonat
zuletzt war sie kontinuierlich
zurückgegangen ist das jetzt eine
Trendwende nein sagen die Experten denn
vor einem Jahr hatte die Regierung des
neuen euro-ticket und den Tankrabatt
eingeführt das verzerrt die Zahlen ohne
diesen Effekt wäre die Teuerungsrate
wohl weiter gesunken
Rassismus gegenüber Muslimen und
pauschale Islamfeindlichkeit sind in
Deutschland weit verbreitet zu diesem
Ergebnis kommt ein von der
Bundesregierung eingesetzter Expertenrat
in seinem Abschlussbericht etwa
fünfeinhalb Millionen Muslime leben in
Deutschland und die werden oft als fremd
und Angehörige einer rückständigen
Religion wahrgenommen laut Studie stimmt
etwa jeder Zweite in Deutschland
muslimfeindlichen Aussagen zu mehr von
Cengiz Ünal
in der türkisch geprägten Keupstraße in
Köln wissen die Anwohner was
muslimfeindlichkeit bedeutet verbale
Angriffe und Vorurteile haben hier schon
viele erlebt auch Julia ist da sie ist
in Deutschland geboren kennt das Leben
hier seit über 40 Jahren
es wird ein bestimmtes Bild
durch die Medien dargestellt dass man
sobald man halt Moslems hört oder Islam
das ist dann immer irgendwie mit Terror
in Verbindung gebracht wird und das ist
halt nicht schön
Vorurteile gegenüber Muslime sind in
weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung verbreitet
zu diesem Ergebnis kommen unabhängige
Experten die zum ersten Mal im Auftrag
einer Bundesregierung die Verbreitung
von muslimfeindlichkeit in Deutschland
untersuchten
Feindlichkeit ist eine Alltagserfahrung
für sehr viele Menschen in diesem Land
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt auf dem
Wohnungsmarkt im Bildungsbereich im
öffentlichen Raum das führt zu einem
Vertrauensverlust im Alltag der Menschen
898 Fälle von anti-muslimischem
Rassismus wurden im vergangenen Jahr in
Deutschland registriert meistens geht es
um verbale Angriffe lautes Berichts
stimmt jeder zweite Deutsche
muslimfeindlichen Aussagen zu wie Jungen
die Scheiße bauen oder Mädchen die
verheiratet werden
Abwertungen und Anfeindungen erlebt auch
Jasmin jomny die wie viele
nordafrikanerinnen im Alltag Kopftuch
trägt ich habe schon Sprüche abbekommen
ich nafte isoia zurück obwohl ich ja
hier geboren bin und Deutschland mein
Land ist mit dem Bericht gab der
Expertenkreis auch eine
Handlungsempfehlung ein zentraler Punkt
der Staat muss sich mehr gegen
Diskriminierung engagieren ich finde man
muss jetzt dagegen steuern weil
Deutschland ist bunt Deutschland sind
Ausländer konsequent gegen Rassismus und
Hass Vorgehen das ist die Forderung des
expertenkreises
die Krankenhäuser in Deutschland
brauchen eine Reform darüber sind sich
eigentlich alle einig und Länder und die
Krankenhäuser selbst aber wie
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat
heute mit den Ländern über Eckpunkte
beraten und harmonisch lief das nicht
jetzt ein kurzer Blick auf die
Ausgangslage fast 1900 Krankenhäuser
gibt es in Deutschland 11 Prozent sind
akut von der insolvenzbedroht und mehr
noch es fehlt das Personal um alle
Kliniken weiter zu betreiben dritter
Mann
das Klinikum Spremberg in Brandenburg
ist für zwei Jahre gerettet die
Mitarbeitenden hatten sogar auf einen
Teil ihres Gehalts verzichtet um ihre
Klinik um ihre Arbeitsplätze zu retten
es geht um die Existenz vieler
Krankenhäuser die
landesgesundheitsminister und
Ministerinnen heute bei Lauterbach mit
protestpapier im Gepäck und Wut im Bauch
unsicher ob es überhaupt eine
Pressekonferenz geben würde so groß ist
der Streit dann findet sie doch statt
die Länder wollen mehr Geld für den
reformübergang Lauterbach sagt ich habe
keinen Spielraum
eine allgemeine Rettungsaktion für alle
Krankenhäuser im System an der Gießkanne
erschöpft sich über alle Krankenhause
dafür fehlt dem Bund das Geld und das
auch unklar wozu das führen würde der
Landesminister aus Baden-Württemberg
sichtlich geladen Lauterbach will
offenlegen welche Krankenhäuser schlecht
und welche gut sind er will Qualitäts-
hohe Kliniken an dem Pranger gestellt
was wir nicht wollen ist dass er bloße
levelung suggeriert nur dieses Level an
jede Woche kommt ein Klinik ein Kreistag
zu mir oh my Krankenhaus die nikot 40
Millionen Euro geben habe in Hohenlohe
in Öhringen weiß gar nicht zu welches
Level es gehört es ist natürlich ein
Zeichen und kein Zufall dass der
bayerische Gesundheitsminister an einem
anderen Ort ein Statement gibt
Spezialisierung ja aber nicht pauschal
sagen es gibt hier wenige gute Qualität
und es hat alles nur mit
Wirtschaftlichkeit zu tun das trifft die
Menschen draußen die dort arbeiten ganz
massiv die Reform soll Anfang nächsten
Jahres kommen bis dahin geht es um
wesentlich mehr als nur um einige
Details
der Bund steckt 900 Millionen Euro
zusätzlich in die Elektromobilität mit
einer halben Milliarde Euro werden
Privathaushalte gefördert die
Ladestation kombiniert mit
Photovoltaik-Anlagen und Stromspeichern
einrichten ein weiteres Programm soll
taxi-firmen Lieferdienste oder
Handwerker beim Umstieg auf E-Fahrzeuge
unterstützen ja die leistungsstarken
Batterien für die E-Autos die werden ja
noch überwiegend entfernt Ost produziert
um unabhängiger zu werden soll unter
anderem ein neues Werk von BASF im
brandenburgischen Schwarzheide helfen
von Bund und Land mit 175 Millionen Euro
gefördert werden dort jährliche
Rohstoffe für Batterien für 400 000
Elektroautos hergestellt und demnächst
Batterien recycelt denn da hat die EU
hohe Quoten festgelegt für Lithium
künftig 80 für Kobalt und Nickel sogar
95% aus Schwarzheide berichtet Nicola
Albrecht
mitten in einer bislangstrukturschwachen
Gegend im südlichen Brandenburg wird sie
heute morgen eröffnet die erste
vollautomatisierte Fabrik für die
Herstellung des Grundstoffs von
Batterien in ganz Europa eine
Recyclinganlage kommt demnächst hinzu
und das loggt auch Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck an denn genau hier sollen nicht
weniger als das Ende der Abhängigkeit
Deutschlands von chinesischen Batterien
und Rohstoffimporten eingeläutet werden
wie diesen nicht leisten komplett
angewiesen zu sein auf die
Produktionsketten die uns abhängig
machen ein gewissen Anteil der
Produktion müssen wir aus
wohlverstandenen Gründen der
europäischen Souveränität hier in Europa
heimisch machen Batterie Recycling auch
ein zentraler Baustein für die
Energiewende die Verfahren zur
Rückgewinnung wichtiger Metalle sind
allerdings aufwendig zunächst werden die
einzelnen batteriemodule geschreddert
das grobe Pulver wird dann von anderen
Stoffen wie zum Beispiel Kunststoffen
getrennt es die sogenannte schwarze
Masse sie enthält die wertvollen Metalle
wie Kobalt Lithium und Nickel die dann
durch ein chemisches Verfahren
extrahiert und damit wiedergewonnen
werden ein weiterer Knackpunkt neben der
Komplexität des Verfahrens ist
allerdings die Batterien wenn man die
produziert und entwickelt dass man schon
im Hinterkopf hat die wird man
irgendwann Recycling müssen das heißt
dass man das das Produktdesign auch auf
die Recyclingfähigkeit auslegt dann wird
aktuell wird dann noch kein großer Fokus
draufgelegt und somit ist jetzt Tempo
gefragt in Wissenschaft und Industrie
in Österreich hat die Polizei ein großes
Waffenlager ausgehoben bei Rockern die
der rechtsextreme Szene zugerechnet
werden es gebe Überschneidungen von
organisierter Kriminalität und
Rechtsextremismus sagen die Ermittler 10
Mitglieder der bandidos-gruppe wurden
festgenommen die Polizei fand unter
anderem Maschinengewehre Granatwerfer
rund 100 Pistolen und Munition außerdem
verbotenen S-Bahnen und Schriften und
über eine halbe Million Euro
das Unternehmen Virgin Galactic des
britischen Milliardärs Branson hat
erfolgreich seinen ersten kommerziellen
Weltraumflug absolviert die Rakete wurde
erst mit einem Trägerflugzeug auf 15.000
Meter Höhe transportiert und hat sich
dann abgekoppelt mit eigenem
antriebfloxidant auf über 80.000 m Gäste
des ersten flugs waren drei Italiener
zwei Mitglieder der Luftwaffe und ein
Ingenieur ein Ticket für ein paar
Minuten im All soll rund 450.000 Kosten
so wir sind beim Sport also bei der
Fußballnationalmannschaft der Männer
läuft es nicht aber bei der U21 Katja
auch nicht definitiv nicht die
Mannschaft von Antonio di salvo ist in
der Vorrunde der U21 em die in Georgien
und Rumänien stattfindet ausgeschieden
und nicht irgendwie sondern gänzlich
ohne Sieg als Gruppen letzte und einem
02 gestern Abend gegen England
hängende Köpfe geplatzte Hoffnungen
Deutschlands Fußballnachwuchs vor zwei
Jahren noch Titelträger muss die
em-vorzeitig verlassen auch Trainer die
salvo kann nichts daran ändern im
Endeffekt es ist halt so dass dass wir
unsere Qualitäten mit mit dem
vorhandenen Kader nicht haben auch schon
können mühelos abgehängt die deutschen
Abwehrspieler das 0:1 durch Archer ein
früher nackten Schlag Gegner England in
allen Belangen reifer bei 0:2 sind sie
in der Überzahl
Elliot kann trotzdem abschließen es
besteht dringender Handlungsbedarf sonst
ziehen Nationen wie England Frankreich
oder Spanien dauerhaft davon wir sind
viel zu langsam wir wünschen uns
Intensität Tempo Dynamik auf dem Platz
und neben dem Platz das schwache
Abschneiden kostet die Olympiateilnahme
und aus diesem Kader drängt sich auch
keiner für die EM der
ann-nationalmannschaft und hat sie
fliegt auf
wir bleiben beim Fußball und nun ist das
was schon länger gemunkelt wurde fix
Nationalspieler Kai havertzwechselt in
der Premier League innerhalb Londons vom
FC Chelsea zum FC Arsenal angeblich
zahlt Arsenal 75 Millionen Euro für den
24-Jährigen und für den 31-Jährigen
Tennisprofi Jannik hanfmann läuft das
bestens er hat beim ATP Turnier auf
Mallorca das Halbfinale erreicht der
Karlsruher besiegte den Spanier
Feliciano Lopez souverän nach nur einer
Stunde und 10 Minuten mit sechs zu zwei
sechs zu vier und trifft nun auf einen
Franzosen entweder auf Adrian marnerino
oder corenta Mut
[Applaus]
in einer Woche beginnen die Finals die
Tage der Deutschen Meisterschaften zur
Einstimmung gab's heute eine
Pressekonferenz und vor allem in
Duisburg und Düsseldorf werden in 18
Sportarten insgesamt 159 Titel vergeben
die ARD und das ZDF übertragen von
Donnerstag bis Sonntag mehr als 25
Stunden im Fernsehen und 70 Stunden im
Livestream und Düsseldorfs Obi Keller
sagte könnte ein Testlauf für eine
mögliche Olympia-Bewerbung werden aha
aha danke Katja ja die Wetteraussichten
die gibt's gleich mit den terli um 21:45
Uhr
schönen Dank fürs zuschauen und noch
einen entspannten Abend für Sie
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ein kleiner
Rückblick in den Juni vor allem der
Regen der war zu wenig in diesem Monat
nur 60 Prozent der üblichen Regenmenge
ist runtergekommen der meiste Regen kam
kompakt runter mit dem Unwetter tief
hier über der Mitte etwa in
Schleswig-Holstein hat's kaum geregnet
und es war der 14 Juni in Folge der
tatsächlich zu warm war so viel zur
Statistik und beim Wetter haben wir es
hier mit einer Kaltfront zu tun die
bringt weiteren Regen durchaus auch
kräftigere Atem im Osten und auch im
Süden einzelne Unwetter sind durchaus
möglich der Nacht ist der Regen schon
dabei mit Gewittern durchsetzt zieht
südostwärts bei tiefsten Temperaturen
von 12 Grad in den Alpen und 18 Grad im
Südwesten das ist die Temperaturspanne
ja und morgen am Nachmittag sieht so aus
im Osten noch Gewitter kräftig und im
Süden auch teils Unwetter ansonsten
lockets von Westen ja schon wieder auf
und die Temperaturen steigen auf 27 Grad
im Osten und 19 Grad am Alpenrand
weitere schauen Gewitter gibt es
durchaus aber die sind nicht mehr ganz
so heftig und am Wochenende am Sonntag
dann mehr Lücken und damit ein schöner
Abend